let's go to james in oshkosh wisconsin
hey dr dolony how are you doing this
morning i'm doing good my man how can i
help
uh just first off wanted to tell you how
much i'm loving the show so far it's
been a great
addition to the ramsey network thank you
so much brother i appreciate it
uh so i just had uh more of a brief
question
uh where i was wondering if you could
provide some clarification
you got it what's up uh i was wondering
at what point
do you simply go from hustling to get
ahead
to becoming a workaholic especially for
those of us that are in baby step
four and beyond as well as if you are
a workaholic and have stepped over that
line how do you
break that addiction to work hmm okay so
for those who don't know what baby steps
are i'm going to put it in the show
notes here
he's talking about dave ramsey's baby
steps to get out of debt
and um the first three steps
are recognizing you got a problem and
getting an emergency fund together
and then running like crazy he calls it
gazelle intense to get out of debt
pay things off and then you want to get
an emergency fund so that if things
happen
not if when things happen you're going
to borrow from yourself not from a
credit card
and you never have to be in debt you
never have to be a slave to somebody
else to some big company to some
department store ever again
so then when you get into baby step four
right like james is talking about here
baby step four is um starting to save
for retirement i'm gonna pay my house
completely off
i'm saving for my kids college and so j
uh what we what we find often james is
that folks get
gazelle intense and they're hustling
right you got a side job you got two
jobs you got three jobs because you're
doing everything you can to get this
debt paid off as fast as possible
and then that hustle becomes a way of
life you get to where you start running
everywhere
right and at some point that stress
destroys your relationships and destroys
you
fair yep okay
so i here's how i delineate the two
hustling is has a goal to it
i'm going to try to pay this stuff off
i'm going to have a second and a third
job
so that i can get that emergency fund so
that i can finally be safe
i'm gonna picture a gazelle and i'm
gonna sprint through this
land where there are lions until i can
get on high ground where i can see
all around me and then i can stop for a
second and rest and eat
and rejoin my community right
a a workaholic is somebody who is
making their identity by how busy they
are it's an addiction
it's the same addiction as alcohol
as food as like sex and pornography
addiction is addiction as addiction is
addiction and so
the way i would tell you james that you
know you have crossed the line between
hustling
and workaholic that you are addicted to
busyness
is when you shift from working with a
partner with an accountability person
with your spouse
towards a common goal we're going to
live in a crazy season and pay all this
junk off
my wife and i did that we sold our house
moved into a residence hall we paid off
i think it was 106 grand
in um in a year a year and a half we
went
nuts i was working three jobs she was
working one full-time job
and we had a two-year-old and we had we
lived in a residence hall in a dorm
we sucked it up for a crazy sprint and
then we couldn't keep living like that
if you find yourself addicted to work or
you're avoiding
relationships where you're staying at
work an hour or two
later and you're not going home if
when your wife or your kids go to bed
you're looking for another job and
another job and another job and
james i've been there dude um when you
are when you meet somebody and they say
hey
um my name's rick what's your name and
you say hey i'm james i'm and you
the next thing you give is your job you
got a problem
you are making your identity about what
you do not about who you are
and so when you make your identity about
what you do
then the temptation is to be leaning on
that all of the time
and i will tell you now i'll tell
everybody this
over and over and over especially men
are
are socialized to have their value and
their worth beyond what they achieve
what they accomplish somebody uh sent me
a
instagram once that was like you're
wrong daloni it's not human beings
it's human doings they're only worth
what they do bullcrap
bullcrap on a stick in a box with a bow
on it
it's ridiculous you got
value and when you start using your work
to numb
feelings to numb disconnection to give
you an excuse to not go home
to not go out and be with your friends
if you're single that's when you know
you've got an addiction
if you can't go through a weekend
without checking your email
if you can't take a vacation if you
haven't taken a vacation in three years
and four years
and that's just rolling up and up and up
if you're sick and you're going to work
anyway
that's when you know it's awesome
awesome question james we get that
a lot here and i want folks to know who
you are is not what you do who you are
it's not how busy you are
that's a crazy endless way of living
your life that only
creates graves and punishment for
everybody